all right I guess there's still some
people filtering in but let's get
started so thank you for coming to my
talk and this is not my first time in
Portugal
I've spent a bit of a time in the
Algarve before but that's kind of a bit
different like I'm always surrounded by
English and Germans and Dutch people so
I'm told that this is the real Portugal
right is that right yeah so and it's
it's really good actually to be
surrounded by Portuguese people actually
speaking Portuguese in Portugal that's
definitely a bit different to the
Algarve so my name is Adam I am from the
from Switzerland I was born and raised
in the UK and I work for a company
called particular software where the
makers of a product called end service
bus has anyone heard of any service bus
that's a few of us that's good to see so
I'm not going to talk about that today I
will say that our company our mission is
to make organisations better at
delivering complex software systems now
in doing that we speak to a lot of
customers people come to us with all
kinds of really kind of difficult
problems and they're usually centered
around shuffling data around versioning
components with respect to other
components rolling out components in
tandem because they're coupled and that
kind of thing and it's very often in
these conversations that we realise
fairly early on you know what if the
service boundaries were a bit different
if things were sliced up in a different
way if the components were shaped
slightly differently we probably
wouldn't be having this conversation the
problem you came to us with probably
wouldn't exist and I think it's one of
those things that's kind of at the root
of the problem so I see a lot of other
problems coming out of this so if you
were to say well this problem causes
these problems and those problems cause
those problems you end up with a kind of
tree of problems this is somewhere near
the root finding your service boundaries
so I think it's really important to talk
about now I may during this talk take
some of the ideas that you're used to
and some of those a lot of the things
you've read about and been taught and I
may just turn them
upside down now if that happens that's
expected that's the intention it may
raise a lot of questions I don't know if
we'll have time for a Q&A before this
session is finished but I'm gonna be
around for the rest of the conference my
twitter handles on the top right so you
know don't hesitate to get in contact
with me anytime and I like to be
challenged on this stuff that's when a
lot of the most interesting conversation
takes place so let's have a look at a
system right now this is a system
doesn't really matter what it is like
this could be classes that could be
functions there could be methods but we
tend to structure things in this kind of
way right we tend to have different
components calling other components we
don't just write program main and put
everything in there right yes I hope you
don't do that I used to do that back in
the 80s when I taught myself computing
and taught myself how to program but
things have moved on since then so we
tend to create classes or functions or
methods and that actually that's quite
nice right you can kind of tell what's
going on there's quite a nice bit of
structure to it you can tell it is some
kind of rare of responsibility up here
if you drill down a bit further there's
an area of responsibility here and
things can look quite nice this diagram
might be quite useful
now what tends to happen is the business
will come along and they'll say well you
know I was out jogging this morning and
I had a great idea my great new feature
we're gonna make a ton ton more money
and you think about it and you think
well we can do this right I think we can
make this work but what I need to do is
I need to make a change up here and I
need some data from some kind of class
down here let's just say these are
classes for argument's sake now there's
nothing in our architectural constraints
to stop us doing this right because each
class is a nice encapsulation it has an
interface that's what classes are
designed for right one class calls
another class so you go ahead and you
just try and make the call and things
kind of work out so you think well it's
not mess a diagram up much and you roll
that out to production and yes you make
a whole load more money and everyone's
happy
few weeks later the business come along
and say well I was I was playing golf
this weekend and
me and the partners had a great idea
we've got a great new feature lined up
we're gonna make a tunnel owed money and
you think well we actually need to make
a change up here and we need some data
from something down here now the last
time we did that three weeks ago that
worked out okay right really cause any
problems so you think well let's try the
same thing again let's just make this
classic last call we're not violating
any interfaces or anything like that and
you make the change roll out into
production you make a ton of money
everyone's happy sooner or later you
find yourself doing the same thing again
and I think you're getting an idea of
where I'm going with this now right over
time and it might be a long period of
time it might be six months it might be
a year it might be eighteen months you
may find yourself going towards this
kind of situation now no one intends to
do this right no one sets out to do this
no one wants to create a play at
spaghetti but I've seen this happen time
and time again and the problem is that
the diagram itself starts to lose its
value because you speak to your
colleague and you say okay that feature
we rolled out last week did you use a
system diagram for that and they say
that thing I haven't looked at that in
months it is absolutely useless so you
may as well just take the lines away and
just have a bunch of boxes right now
individually you look at these classes
and each class kind of makes sense it's
got a nice interface it's got a nice
name it's got nicely named methods and
that's fine but you want to make a
change it's really difficult to tell
what class is calling what class but you
kind of have to go and try then you end
up breaking something somewhere else so
you fix that then you break something
else and you fix that and you end up in
this kind of code Safari I'll kind of
edit in price and re-edit something and
pray it's going to work and it becomes
really difficult to look at these things
in isolation you can't really look at
them in isolation anymore so the diagram
again is kind of useless right you might
as well have one big box now this is the
point where some people call this
something like a big ball of mud does
anyone has anyone seen this
architectural pattern during their
careers this a few of you unfortunately
I
most of the systems I've dealt with in
my career
unfortunately follow this architectural
style alright that's a sad truth but the
thing is we know we can do better right
so we read about service-oriented
architecture we really know about micro
services and other approaches and we
work out that if we split this up into
different services things might be a bit
easier to manage we can think about one
of these at a time change it
independently and I've deliberately
drawn very thin lines between them
because we want a loose amount of
coupling between them we don't have to
change always change two at the same
time or three at a same time
one loose small amount of information
going between these things if possible
that's great the business will come
along and they'll say well I was what
we're doing now I was at dinner party
last night and I spoke to one of the
partners who made this great new idea
like a ton of money with this new
feature and you think right we can do
this what we need is a piece of data
from this service here in this service
over here and it might be something
really innocuous like a price right so
the price of a product you know 99 euros
how much harm can that cause it's just a
number we just slightly redefine the
service interface and we can make that
call so you go ahead and you take the
plunge and make the call you roll out an
to production you're making a whole loan
you a whole load of new money and
everyone's happy sooner or later the
business come along and say well you
know I was doing yoga this morning and I
had a great new idea for a new feature
we're gonna make a ton of money and you
realize well we kind of need to do the
same thing again need to make a need to
get something from this service and the
service up here now I'm sure you've
worked out where I'm going with it as
well right over time and remember this
might be a long period of time it might
be months it might be a year it might be
more you may end up with this kind of
situation right it's another kind of
plate of spaghetti and as we've seen
when we're in this situation we can't
use a diagram anymore the can't reuse
the lines anymore may as well take them
away we may as well take the box is the
way we're back to the big ball of mud
only this time it's a big ball of mud a
little different
because you've rolled it out in four
machines they're talking to each other
each other over the network right in
even if it's localhost even they've on
the same machine that's a lot more
expensive than classic last calls
you've got Network latency network
outages you've got to roll out two
things three things or even all four
things at the same time we deployment
models more complicated you've ended up
in a worse situation than you started
with right you might as well just done
the big wall of mud in one big process
and that's a shame because
service-oriented architecture on
micro-services was supposed to help us
but we've ended up in a worse situation
by trying that but we can avoid that all
right so let's dig into the detail of a
some of us have a use case so I'm gonna
talk about Amazon now I'm sure that most
of you have bought something on Amazon
or something similar at some stage when
you buy something on Amazon you load you
up your basket with stuff and you get
all excited and they go right I'm gonna
place my order now and what happens is
you start a workflow right so the
beginning of that workflow is place the
order
now what happens then is you're asked
for say shipping address right so you
enter your shipping details of my books
in here and you press ship to this
address you enter your credit card
details right how am I gonna pay for
this thing and so forth with shipping
options and blah blah blah and all the
rest of it and then you come to the end
of the workflow and you actually say
place your order in euros or whatever
excuse me now Amazon is a highly
service-oriented company right there is
no kind of one terabyte Amazon XE right
it is this spin off a bit more than that
right it's it's it's actually a
multitude of different services you know
if you read stuff about Amazon
architecture it's fascinating there roll
out multiple times a day it's really
it's one of the most service-oriented
companies in the world
Jeff Beezus actually the CEO he sent out
a memo once to the entire company to say
everything you do must be service
oriented anything anyone found not to be
doing that will
fired he actually sent that email so
it's very highly service oriented now
let's have a look at how that might look
in the backend right this is a slightly
simplified model of the Amazon back-end
with sales finance and shipping as
different services now when we get to
the end of that work for we place the
order so we send a command to sales to
say place the order sales does it was it
what it needs to do so it will say is
this product still for sale have you got
it in stock if we haven't come any order
more are we allowed to sell it in this
country you know whatever kind of thing
as sales does and if that's all
satisfied it says right
okay I'm gonna create the order in the
database you know with an order ID
whatever and it says it raises an event
to say that the orders been placed
finance and shipping subscribe to that
event so Finance gets a message to say
with the orders been placed so it builds
for that order might charge as a credit
card raises another event say the orders
been billed for when shipping has seen
that the orders been placed and the
orders been billed it goes ahead and
actually ships the order right calls
FedEx ecause DHL does whatever it needs
to do and it may raise another event say
order shipped which something else might
subscribe to and so forth and so forth
and so forth now the question is what do
we need to put on these events in order
to make this work
so one way of doing it is to say well
order placed must have all the shipping
details on it and it must have all the
billing details on it so that when
finance of shipping receive those
messages finance can propagate that on
to order billed or if or shipping could
just read it or forward a place in the
first place and they can all do their
work right because that initial event is
going to contain the shipping details
and the credit card details now that
would work right there's no reason that
wouldn't work but what's the problem
with that button
extending it changing it yes so so and
and the reason that changing is a
problem is because of coupling right
we're back to this highly couple
situation with sharing data because just
as you say if you want to extend it will
change it right let's say we want to
introduce Bitcoin payment right
you don't supply credit card details you
supply or whatever is a Bitcoin wallet
address or something like that I'm not -
I'm not a Bitcoin expert what happens if
you want to send ebooks we don't send an
e-book to an address that would just be
weird
I mean you guess you couldn't let us be
key but they'll just be weird right you
just send them an email with a link so
if we want to start introducing Bitcoin
payment or ebooks we'll have to make a
whole load of changes in sales so that
it knows how to ship ebooks and it knows
how to charge in Bitcoin so it can pass
information on to shipping and on to
finance and so forth and so forth and
then if you look at that event you're
gonna have all kinds of weird null
ability rules like oh well either the
shipping address has got to be not null
or the email address for the book has
got me not null or the credit cards got
to be not null the Bitcoin not not only
end up with this kind of null ability
soup and the event is getting fatter and
fatter and a fatter and fatter right
we've got a big fat event with loads of
loads of stuff on it and that means we
have to roll out these services all the
same time and although they can all talk
to each other that new information now
what if we take that fat of em and we
slim it down to a very thin event what
if we can slim it all the way down to
just an ID literally just an event
saying order placed with an order ID on
it like order one two three or do it
whatever it needs to be what can happen
then is sales can say orders been placed
and your ID is one two three finance can
say our order one two three I know how
to build for that and it goes and
charges a credit card or it goes and
charges a Bitcoin address whatever
shipping says ah the orders been placed
the orders been billed the ID is one two
three I know how to ship order ID one
two three and it goes and sends it to a
physical address where it sends an email
it does whatever it needs to do that
sounds great but the problem is that
we've got we've got a kind of chicken
and egg problem here right because sales
is creating the order right it's
creating the order ID in the database so
how can finance possibly know about
order ID one two three before it's
received the event and the same with
shipping how can it know now until now
we've assumed that the order ID is going
to be created at this moment right and
now remember that's the end of the
workflow what if we turn that upside
down and we say let's create the ID at
the beginning of the workflow so you can
actually create it here when you say
proceed to checkout when you say proceed
to checkout before you go through that
whole workflow you already create the
order ID and you can even do this
client-side right you can set a
client-side order ID is a gooood what
happens now is we guarantee our workflow
when we get to here we already know the
order ID when we click ship to this
address we actually send a message to
the fight to the shipping service to say
this is the address for order 1 2 3 when
we go to the credit-card details we
already send a message to the finance
server to say these the credit-card
details for order 1 2 3 right or the
Bitcoin address or back here these are
the this is the email address for that
for the e-book and so forth and so forth
and so forth until you get to the end of
the workflow right you click that button
and now this command comes in and when
Finance receives order placed order 1 2
3 remember we've already told the
finance service what the credit card
details are 4 2 1 2 3
we've already told the shipping service
what the credit card details are what
the physical address of the email
address is 4 2 1 2 3
during the workflow right now we can
slim down that event to just an ID
because those services are sitting there
ready with that data already right very
very low amount of coupling and the
weird trick that's allowed us to do that
it's the crate the ID up front instead
of at the end now you may be thinking at
this point well that's all well and good
but
if someone never gets to that point what
if someone never actually says place
your order they filled in all these
details blood little bit blah and then
their wife or husband walks through the
door and I get a guilty feeling and they
kind of close the browser and so I
shouldn't be spending that money after
all now shouldn't something come along
and clear up that data right they've got
this redundant rubbish sitting around
the database but it's it really
redundant is it really rubbish now isn't
it interesting to know which orders went
to completion which didn't is there some
kind of trend we can spot there
is this certain group of products going
to completion and this certain other
good products and not going to
completion can we a be test that what
can we do to improve that conversion to
actually actually clicking the place
order at the end this is really rich
business analytics right a lot of
businesses would kill for that
information so ask yourself is it
actually redundant and it doesn't
necessarily have to be in the database I
mean if it is it's just a row in the
database right which is pretty cheap to
store but you've got to be careful about
holding credit card details right so
that could just be in session statement
right the user closes browser the
session expires and the data goes so
don't worry too much about redundant
data which as you can see is in many
cases is not redundant at all actually
very valuable so this is what we ended
up with and why did we end up with that
well it's because it all started here
right it all started with the sharing of
data so now we can start to define kind
of water service is but first of all
what a service is not a service is not
something that is just kind of something
with functionality like a validation or
a calculation or something like that
that that is what a function is right
that's kind of the definition of what a
function is it's not something which
gives you crud operations on data you
know just changing records yeah that's
what a database is and really
importantly if you just put HTTP on top
of a database you know you sprinkle this
kind of magic asp.net core magic dust
over a database it doesn't suddenly make
it a service
right contrary to a lot of the articles
that appeared on the and the web a while
ago it doesn't suddenly make it a
service right all you've done is it's
still a database you've just changed the
technical entry point from database
connection to HTTP a service is the
technical Authority for a specific
business capability and really
importantly all data and business rules
reside within the service right you can
think of it as bounded context if you
like if you if you're kind of a narrow
Kevin is the main driven design fan and
equally importantly is that nothing is
left over after you after you identify
your services you know service a service
being service see it's not that you then
have this other stuff on the side
you know there's kind of we don't know
where to put that we're just you're just
kind of chuck it to the side somewhere
you need to place everything in some
kind of service now if you think about
it the code we write is for some
business purpose right we don't just
write code for fun although if your
projects failing you know it's gonna
fail and I forgive you for going and
learning rust or something but and the
normal ideal circumstances will write in
code for business purposes and if the
service is the technical authority for
any specific business capability that
leads us to the fact that all code must
belong within cut within some kind of
service and it's really important
because when you find that stuff that's
really difficult to place that's when
you ask and answer the most difficult
questions and that's where that's where
those service boundaries start to get
really crisp and start to get really
defined so if you have this escape hatch
of other stuff left over you avoid that
and you avoid the benefit of asking and
answering those pretty difficult
questions if you look at in terms of
systems so sometimes it's very tempting
to build or to name services after kind
of systems that exist has anyone ever
heard the term backend service right
I've heard that a lot of times in my
career this is the back-end service this
is the front-end service
but the thing is these are these are
technical concerns right services are
logical concerns they kind of cut across
these things now the implication of that
is that you may have a service which
ships an objective-c component or
xamarin or whatever it is these days a
dotnet component and the Java component
you may have a system which consists of
components from service one service two
in service three it's kind of like you
know when you play with Lego and you
have that kind of green board and then
you might have piles of bricks and I was
very kind of specific about this when I
was my so play with Lego I said like red
bricks yellow bricks and white bricks or
large medium and small and I kind of
pick a brick from each pile put it on
the green board and build something
right think of those as your services
you're taking bits from each service
putting it onto the green board and
building a system which might be a
mobile app services are logical design
time concerns with business aligned
boundaries systems are physical runtime
concerns with technically aligned
boundaries okay services logical design
time business systems physical runtime
technical now if this one thing I want
you to take from this talk right it is
this thing that logical does not equal
physical I think the conflation of the
logical and physical it's even if you
think about that tree of problems it's
even a step below finally the right
service boundaries there's so many times
I've seen the wrong service boundaries
used because the logical gets conflated
with the physical all right that's
something that is that is kind of a
little bit endemic and the micro
services literature is that the physical
micro service is also the logical
service I'll come to that a bit more in
a minute but as I say if there's one
thing I'd like you to take from this
talk you know even if you're just gonna
kind of zone out for the rest of it and
go on slack or whatever it's logical
does not equal physical
so let's have a look at a bit more of a
concrete example now you might speak to
the business and they might say to you
okay we've got customers and products
right we sell products the customers
let's start there so the first thing you
do you get around the whiteboard and you
draw a box for customers and you draw a
box for products and they start telling
you about the details and you say ok
well that's interesting but let's get
into the detail a little bit later tell
us more about the high level concepts
right so you start drawing more boxes
and then you end up finding out that a
customer has a first name and a customer
has a last name
customers of status prod as a name
description the price and the
interesting thing about this is that
businesses often don't know what they
want but they almost know almost always
know what they don't want and you can
take advantage of that you can ask
really dumb questions you can use a
technique which I call anti requirements
and anti requirements and involves
asking silly questions like if the
customers first name begins with an S
does that affect their status now that
point you're gonna get some puzzled
looks and so you what you don't you
really have no idea about this domain at
all have you not that that is so dumb
not only would we never do that no one
in this entire industry we do anything
so stupid
now don't be afraid when that happens
because you've just struck gold because
what are they just told you they've just
told you a stable business rule they've
just told you that there's no
relationship with a customer name and
their status so why are they in the same
box I'm not seeing a good reason for
them to be in the same box right now I'm
gonna put them in separate piles right I
don't really know what these things are
just yet but I think I see that customer
state has no relationship with customer
name so I'm gonna put them in two
separate piles and at this stage of
modeling this is what you're trying to
do you're trying to try to create
different piles of stuff different piles
of related stuff and these are not you
know this is not a
laughs or a row in the database or
anything like that this is a logical
modeling exercise we're just putting
logically related stuff in the same pile
and we're gonna see how that works out
then we see that customer status what's
kind of sitting now on its own looking a
bit lonely so what is the point of that
thing was it there for and the business
will say to you well oh we use that to
work out how much to charge the customer
so if they're a gold customer they get
20% off if there are silver customer
they get 10% off everyone else pays full
price okay so you just a price right so
customer status has got something to do
with price right okay so let's let's try
that on for size let's put them in the
same pile right there's somehow related
and then you think well what we got left
over got the product name in the
description well they kind of go
together right if something is if
something is a Dulux something or other
you want the description to tell you why
right and why it's so great why you
should buy it so you put theirs in
another pile down here now that's led us
to a very different model again this is
a very simple example but you can
imagine more complex examples you get a
radically different model then you would
off with the kind of entity approach and
this is actually quite tough because our
kind of brains and eyes are wired to
look for tangible tangible things right
tangible nameable things so it's kind of
like it's a bit counterintuitive but one
of the tricks you can use is to watch
out for when you hear something like
customer has a first name look out for
that bit in the middle has aa as soon as
you see as soon as you hear has a that's
an alarm bell it's an alarm bell to say
that you're going down with a kind of
entity first high-level approach instead
of looking at the use cases modeling is
about behaviors and scenarios
it's not about tangible things there's
anyone read Eric Evans domain-driven
design book that's quite a few of you so
if you were like me you read the first
half of the book you got really excited
you ran to work and you started writing
value objects entities Negra roots a son
right
I see if you smile as I see I see a bit
of familiarity with that
now Eric said later on that he wished
he'd put that in the second half of the
book because a lot of people read the
first off get all excited and doesn't
read second half right I read the second
half eventually and then later on he
said well I wish I just put the entities
and stuff in an appendix and later on he
actually said I wish I left it out all
together right because it distracted
people with so much from the more
important lessons which were in the
second half of the book now I'll either
go ahead and say it in this context as a
modeling tool entities are bad right and
I know that goes against a lot of what
you've seen and heard right but I truly
believe that entities are bad as a
modeling tool behaviors and scenarios
great you need to look into the detail
you need to look into how the data
relates to each other how what what
actually takes place in typical use case
in scenarios in the system another good
thing here is to not give these name
will not give these things names too
early right I often say just given them
numb dumb names like red green and
yellow or names of planets or names of
cartoon characters it doesn't matter you
might look at it and say well that's
clearly customers that's clearly
products you know etc etc but the
problem is if you name things too early
those names cause two problems first of
all they mislead you so you have a
conversation around the whiteboard with
your domain expert and you say ah well
that's clearly billing right and you put
it in billing just because it's called
billing or you say well that can't
possibly belong in there because that's
marketing right so you don't put it in
there you want to put it in there but
the name stopping you right so don't
name these things too early in fact I
was working at a team once where we just
decided to never give these things
meaningful names all right we actually
use kaiju monsters so like Godzilla and
God Zhu Qian who Darkwood Mothra another
more obscure one so we just left them
with those names forever right because
they're kind of out it's a bit of an
abstract domain with those names are not
going to really add meaningful names are
not gonna add anything so we just left
them called kind of meaningless names
forever
now insurance is another kind of
interesting domain in this context does
anyone here work in insurance one two
three lucky people right so insurance
and tell me if I get this wrong right
but insurance is largely based around
kind of a front office model in the back
office model so you get people selling
policies in the front office and people
dealing with claims in the back office
right and the front office is actually
all about fear right it's about making
people afraid enough about bad things
happening that they're gonna buy
insurance and actually I was - I was in
Russia talking to some people about this
once and they told me that the Russian
word for insurance actually has the word
fear in it all right so there's some
truth to this now the back office on the
other hand they're all about paying as
little as money as possible when a claim
is made alright if I got that about
right yes you're nodding your head so I
guess I have
sounds a bit cutthroat but really you
know that's the model of any business
it's maximum money in minimum money out
now a colleague of mine was actually
called into an insurance company
essentially to look at their service
boundaries to say have we got this right
and what I showed him was this they
showed him a policy service which kind
of represented what the front office do
and a claim service which just kind of
represents what the back office - now I
know next to nothing about the insurance
industry I have no idea how to run this
shorts company but I can look at this
and I can say almost straight away this
is wrong the reason for that is think
about a typical use case what happens
when you make a claim you send it off
you send up a form you might do it
online the claim service receives that
what's the first thing that they do they
start reading the small print they go to
the policy service get the entire policy
including pages and pages of small print
and they go through it with a tooth comb
and work out a if they can get away with
not paying or be how little they can pay
that's a whole load of request/response
between those two services right they
are very very tightly coupled now it's
all very good saying that's wrong but
you know if you're quoting as a
consultant they want to know what's
right okay now this is tough right so
when you're trying to find the right
service boundaries it's often a very
stressful exercise you know you kind of
you kind of find yourself kind of
bumbling around with your eyes closed
bumping into stuff and you've really got
no idea what you're doing and it can
take a while to get that flash of
insight you know three or four days
later you know time passes and imagine
say to where you told us it was all
wrong if you found that what's right yet
oh yeah I'm getting somewhere
even though you're actually not getting
anywhere but eventually hopefully you
get that flash of insight and this is
what it tends to be like and you realize
that in talking to the domaine experts
about all the typical use cases you
realize that home insurance doesn't
actually have much to do with travel
insurance and travel insurance doesn't
have much to do with car insurance
because when I crash my car I don't show
them my sofa right or my cat chews up
the sofa oh that show my cancel plane
ticket right they're very disparate
things so you draw these kind of service
boundaries you do write on our home
insurance around travel insurance around
car insurance you think okay I might
have something here I might just have
something here you examine the use cases
you realize you don't have
request/response going between them and
you think you might be onto something so
it gets the Friday you've just made it
in for the end of the week you book the
biggest meeting room in the building you
call the senior management together you
get a beautiful PowerPoint presentation
together and you stand up and you make
your world-shattering announcement home
insurance is different to travel
insurance travel insurance is different
to car insurance and the business look
at you and they say how much if we paid
you so come in and tell us something
that we've known for our entire careers
something that the industry is known for
a hundred years
now again you've struck gold because
what they're saying is yeah but that's
obvious if you hear
something like that but you know that's
obvious we know that already that's a
really really strong sign you've got
things right now you might think well
why did we waste that entire week having
all those meetings and all those
whiteboard sessions and me getting
stressed and drinking a thousand cups of
coffee why don't we just ask them in the
first place we wouldn't just say to him
in the first place out how is it
organized well the problem is that's
obvious right but so is that and there
are myriad ways of describing this
business right it all depends on who you
talk to what their context is what their
job function is what their motivation is
what they're aspiring to something you
might get lucky right you might just get
lucky in some might say oh yeah we've
got home insurance travel insurance and
car insurance those are our service
families off you go
or they might say we've got a fun office
in the back office or they might say
we've got products customers something
else again
it's not a top-down exercise it's not
drawing the big boxes first and then
looking at a detail it's a bottom-up
exercise right it's looking at the use
cases it's looking at the data that's
involved in the scenarios that will lead
you to the better model and again that
goes against their intuition we usually
want to see a 30,000 foot view first and
then drill down it's the other way and
people often say to me well do I really
need to go into that level of detail do
I really need to start looking at the
use cases and and going into all and
exploring all of that nitty-gritty stuff
and the answer is yes
right and it's not a cheap way of
working right it's an expensive exercise
because it takes time it takes effort
but that's the way the model reveals
itself bottom up not top down now that's
a kind of specific example of
organizations so organizations are
typically split into departments right
departments divisions teams whatever you
whatever you call them organizational
units and it's really tempting to coming
too long as an organization and when you
see oh yeah we've got a marketing
department got a finance department got
a sales apartment
okay great let's just draw our service
boundaries around those and off we go
we're done right now that may have
worked at one time if you think back to
before we put computers in everyone's
desks right before the age of
computerization data existed on paper
paper existed in filing cabinets now the
cost of data access was expensive now if
you were sitting in one end of the
building and you needed papers from the
filing cabinet on that side of the
building on that side of the building
right over in that corner there that's a
very very expensive method of data
access so what you did was you
surrounded yourself with the data you
needed right so the filing cabinets
containing the papers you need were
sitting around you and then you get a
kind of request to do something in and
you kind of go to your filing cabinet
get a piece of paper out you fill out a
form put it in your outbox some will
come along with the trolley and kind of
move it over to someone's inbox they go
to their filing cabinets and get the
information that they need they maybe
tick a box and put it in their out books
and outbox and so on and so on so
organizations were almost forced to be
service oriented right a department
would basically encapsulate a business
function and the data required for that
business function and at that time that
might have been a useful way to start
looking for service boundaries then we
came along with our fancy databases and
our fancy computers we put a computer on
everyone's desk you're a big fat
database in the middle and all of a
sudden data access is really really
cheap basically anyone in the company
can access any dates they want right
it's just a matter of setting a security
flag which is often a case of knowing
the right person so what's happened is
managers have taken advantage of that
managers are in most large companies
motivated to build their org structure
right the more boxes you have underneath
you and the org structure they're more
likelihood you're gonna get a higher
bonusing and get promotion so managers
kind of pick and choose jobs from any
organization have you ever seen
manager leave and then the other
managers kind of fight over the scraps
to take over job functions I see a few
smiles so I've seen that a few times in
companies that I've worked in and the
problem with that is it's not a stable
business abstraction right we want
stable business rules for our boundaries
first of all it changes very often right
I worked in one company where my org
unit used to change six seven or eight
times in a year so if you're modeling
around that you're gonna be changing
your code and ripping everything apart
all the time and the other thing is it
doesn't really represent the business it
really represents a manager's skilar
empire building because the modern
department has become a kind of like
mini Kingdom right or mini Empire
so it's really not a useful tool in most
cases for drawing service boundaries so
beware the organizational structure now
I did promise to talk a little bit about
micro services now I think a lot of
great stuff has come out of the whole
micro services movement so we've got
great stuff around independent
independently deployable units
you know elastic scaling and things like
containers and Kuban Nettie's and all
this kind of stuff and that's all really
great however I do have one big concern
about this which I'll try and illustrate
now micro services are another kind of
thing in our toolkit to battle against
this nemesis of ours a big wall of mud
this is what we're trying to avoid so we
read about micro services and we see
that we really need to split things up
into smaller units so we split things up
into same five micro services and things
are already looking better right we can
look at each of these things in
isolation we've got nice small lines of
communication between them and things
looking quite good then we read another
blog post and it says well you know you
should really have at least 10 micro
services you know fives not really
enough so you split things up a bit more
and you end up with was it 13 micro
services hear anything okay well we must
be doing micro services now right
they're all nice and small and
and then you read some more literature
and it says well each microserver should
really be rewritable within one week or
even worse it should be 300 lines long
on No More or something like that so you
spit them up even more and you end up
with a whole bunch of micro-services
does that look familiar kind of
deliberate and it's looking quite nice
right but the business come along and
they say well you know I was I was out
drinking last night in my buddies and I
had a great new idea of you know we're
gonna we're gonna this is a great new
feature idea we're gonna make a ton of
money and I think we're way actually
need to make a change up here and we
need some data from down here and again
we haven't imposed any other
architectural constraints at this point
right each micro-service has a clearly
defined interface which if we respect it
should not be a problem to make that
call from there to there that's what
they're designed for right so you make
the call Araya and the production you're
making a ton of money and everyone's
happy sooner or later they come along
with a great new idea you know they were
out I know what they're doing this time
I was at a football match had a great
new idea and you find yourself doing the
same thing again we need some data up
here and we need some data from down
there so you make the call and you've
seen this before already right over time
and remember we're talking long periods
of time here we're talking maybe six
months a year 18 months maybe longer you
may end up with this kind of situation
which have already seen before we've
seen we may as well take the lines away
and we just type of boxes away and we're
back to the big wall of mud only this
time it's a big ball of mud with a
difference we've rolled this out into a
hundred docker containers right we've
got this amazing amazing deployment
pipeline where we can deploy all of them
at the same time because we usually need
to because they're so tightly coupled
they're all talking to each other than
other network network couches yeah they
do cause a few problems now and then so
you've ended up with a big ball of mud
microservices edition
and again this is a real shame because
microservices were supposed to help
right we introduced these with all the
best of intentions it was supposed to
help us it was supposed to make things
better unfortunate it's kind of
backfired we've ended up in a worse
situation than we started with
now again what we want is a smaller
number of logical services right these
are logical boxes these are not physical
boxes right with small amounts of
information going between them ideally
just IDs as we've seen now within those
we have different components right we've
already seen how we can take something
from each service and ship it into a
system right so we might have a xamarin
component shipped by each of these three
services we take those three xamarin
components we've put them into a mobile
app we package it deploy and it goes out
to people's phones right that's the
separation of the logical and the
physical once again now within these
services again you might look at these
individual components and say well are
these not micro services within these
logical boundaries so these are logical
boundaries these things in here are
actual physical components that we build
could we not call those micro services
well you could but I prefer to call them
Multan of autonomous components I don't
really like the word micro services for
two reasons
micro right which implies that small is
important and it is not and service
it's another overloading of the term
service and it's highly distracting from
services in the service oriented
architecture context where services are
logical concerns and what I've seen
happen too much within the micro
services movement is too much conflation
of the physical with a logical right
where that's the only architectural
constraint we've got our nice physical
boundaries and we forget about the
larger logical boundaries and the thing
is we split things up within these
logical services for a very different
reason we imagine
that this box down here is something to
do with bank accounts and two of its
responsibilities are creating bank
statements and locking accounts for
fraud so if we suspect there's some kind
of fraudulent activity happening on an
account we send a message to this
service to say lock this account and
that needs to happen instantly right the
business will say - that needs to happen
right now within milliseconds right bank
statements you know they just need to
happen sometime today you know
occasionally if they're a day late it's
not the end of the world so what we do
is we separate those two
responsibilities into two separate
autonomous components we have a
component for bank statements and we
have a component for fraud the component
for bank statements we might put that on
I don't know - two VMs for high
availability you know if one falls over
the other one takes over you know
whatever fraud
we might roll that out on to ten
machines all competing off the same
queue or elastically scale it or do all
kinds of crazy stuff like get all kinds
of container orchestration involved
right that might sound familiar for what
you've read about microservices right
and that's where a lot of the things
that micro services really come into
their own
around these individual small deployable
units so we split these things up for
very different reasons and you might
think well isn't it possible to build a
mini ball of mud right so this one down
here is starting to look a bit complex
right so isn't that possibly becoming
like a little ball of mud of its own now
I'm not going to say that's impossible
right with enough determination you can
make a mess using any architectural
style right but I will say it's less
likely because as I've demonstrated we
split these things up within these
logical boundaries for a very different
reason
- the top-level split which we saw
earlier we split them up for different
levels of SLA we split them up to ship
them into different parts of different
systems so yeah as I said call them
micro services if micro services if you
want but I just don't like that term
right I prefer autonomous components so
we're coming to the end now I've really
just scratched the surface here you know
if you want to know more about this
stuff in a lot more detail this is a guy
called OD de Haan he's the CEO of our
company
Fator in the crater rent service bus he
runs a five-day advanced distributed
systems design course and this is
actually an in-person course that
happens I think four times a year
it's also available as videos now what
I've done here is I've put together a
package this is Godot particular dotnet
slash NDC - porto - 201 2019 if you miss
that just tweet me and I'll gladly to
play with the URL
I've put together a package for you
which is an extract of those videos and
that's completely for free so just
follow that URL grab that video package
and you'll hear a lot more about service
boundaries and less away in a lot more
detail so I'm just gonna finish off with
saying that has anyone has anyone read
the Gang of Four patterns book yeah
that's probably at least half of you so
do you remember when you read about that
next pattern then you run in rushing to
work the next day and implement it and
then the the way you do why you write
your system was the last pattern you
wrote that you read about and in the end
you're kind of using all these pans
because they're really exciting you
really want to now I know I did that
right but this again is not a silver
bullet it's not a golden hammer it's not
something to be used in all
circumstances just like anything and
software now there's anyone here work in
a start-up or a startup ish kind of
environment yeah it's just a few hands
going up alright so for you guys I've
got a little bit of bad news
if you're getting excited about this
kind of stuff and you think this is
interesting
be very wary of using it too
early in this in a startup phase so the
problem is that startups a very good
example of where you might not want to
use at least initially because startups
don't know what their businesses are yet
right it took Facebook quite a while to
realize it's actually a media company
right Facebook puts eyeballs in front of
media it sells the eyeballs to
advertisers right that's a media company
although Facebook doesn't actually
create the content the eyeballs create
their own content so it's very lucrative
I mean that's part of the reason they're
worth so much money
Twitter took them a while to realize how
they were gonna make money and they
ended up rewriting their system
completely now when in the early years
of a startup you basically got a whole
load of great ideas you've got them
spread out on the floor and you're just
making a mess and trying to find out how
you can make something work now my
advice there is just write whatever code
you need to do to prove something right
whatever code you need to do to make
something work and they might say well
but we're gonna have to rewrite it right
because it's going up in the mess well
yes but if you've started modeling your
service boundaries around those initial
ideas when you actually discover what
your business is you're gonna have to
rewrite it right so you're gonna have to
rewrite it either way in the vast
majority of cases so be very wary about
using this too early on in a start-up
scenario as I said it's not a cheap
approach
it's an effortful approach that requires
looking at a lot of detail a lot of
scenarios right so it is an investment
it is a it is an in consider in
considerable investment so I've got a
few minutes left so before I wrap up has
anyone got any questions I want to throw
me this at this time yeah
okay okay so the question is for each of
those autonomous components within a
logical boundary do we actually segment
the database or do we share a database
between the autonomous components and
the answer is you do whatever makes
sense for that service right because
when you're operating within a logical
service boundary as long as that service
boundary is encapsulating all the
business rules and all the data and it's
not revealing any data outside to any
other services you're within your
architectural constraints now for some
services and actually if we go back to
that diagram quickly you'll notice that
this service here the physical boundary
just happens to align with a logical
boundary right there just happens to be
a one to one relationship between the
physical and the logical but it's just
by certainly it's just my it's just
coincidental right it just happens to be
that that makes sense for that service
it's not by architectural constraints
which unfortunately is what a lot of the
micro services literature says is that a
service equals the deplorable unit
equals a logical unit now in the same
way it may make sense for these
components here to share a single
database or it may not because you're
gonna get row level locking contention
on creating bank statements and locking
counts of fraud right so and this is
this is one of the interesting things
once you once you get very solid
business aligned boundaries feel for
your services along stable business
rules to some extent you can kind of go
to town within that service boundary
right you can use a radically different
technology for these back-end components
here to these back-end components here
you know you can use Ruby in one and
Java and the other or Python than one
don't let any other you know you kind of
just do what makes sense for that
service so the answer really there is do
whatever makes sense for that service
right if if these things can cooperate
with each other within data
is fine if not split them up but it's
really your choice because your opera
you're already operating within the
confines of that logical boundary does
that answer the question
yeah any other questions before I wrap
up yeah
okay so the question is between services
all we do is share the ID but within a
service the autonomous components can
share more than just an ID between them
right and basically there's a correct
statement right so there are public
events and there are private events
right so public events would be what
we've seen before in the Amazon example
where we've got an event being published
from one service to another service
right that's a public event the service
is actually publicizing publishing those
events within a service you might have
an event-driven architecture which also
relies on events but because they're all
within one logical boundary they are at
liberty if they want to to share more
data on their events you know those
those are what I would call private
events and there you can kind of do
whatever makes sense for the event for
the for the service as well it's almost
it's actually quite similar to the last
question in that if that makes sense for
that service if it makes sense for these
autonomous component to be publishing
events with more data on them to each
other then yes
although commands versus events is kind
of another very big subject events so
you would you wouldn't really send
commands from one service to another
you'd only publish events with IDs on
them commands tend to have all the
information that is needed to perform
that command on them so you would send
commands within a service but only
publish events between services but
that's a kind of whole nother topic
which unfortunate out of time to get
into okay so as I said I'm gonna be
around for the rest of the conference
please do approach me at any time and
challenge me on this stuff that's when
most of the really interesting
conversations happen when I get
challenged on this and people say well
how can that possibly work and we can
get some have some really interesting
interesting discussions my twitter
handle is up there on top right do tweet
me as well I can open up a DM channel
and i'm really i really enjoy discussing
this stuff so please please don't
hesitate to approach me so i hope you've
enjoyed that i've
you've gonna find it useful I've really
enjoyed talking to you and enjoy the
rest of the conference and thank you
very much
[Applause]